تحت وقع الصدمه والذهول تحدق هذه السيده
الاوكرانيه في هول الدمار الذي لحق بهذه
البنيه السكنيه في مدينه نيبرو الاوكرانيه
والتي تبدو كانها شطرت الى نصفين بعد قصف
صاروخين روسي وسط توقعات بسقوط العشره من
القتلى عمال طوارئ قالوا انهم سمعوا
نداءات استغاثه من تحت انقاذ المبنى
السكني المؤلف من تسعه طوابق في نيترو
ولكن مع انخفاض درجات الحراره تتبدد
الامال في العثور على نجين عمده المدينه
يقدم تفسيرا لما حدث
الصاروخ ضرب البنايه
في الضفه الاخرى من النهر حاول استهداف
المحطه لكن الصاروخ اصاب بنايات سكنيه
هو فيما تتحدث القياده العسكريه الروسيه
عن ضربات صاروخيه استهدفت مراكز القياده
الاوكرانيه في كل ارجاء البلاد واصابت
اهدافها بدقه يقول الجنود الاوكرانيون
انهم يطلقون صواريخ جراند التي تعود الى
عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي على مواقع الجنود
الروس الذين يقاتلون من اجل السيطره على
مدينه بخمت في شرق البلاد ومع احتدام
القتال الميداني يؤكد الامين العام لحلف
شمال الاطلسي السلطان الحرب قد بلغت مرحله
حاسمه وانه من المهم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه الثقيله التي تعاهدت بها عده دول
غربيه منذ بدء الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا
طالب بمزيد من الاسلحه الثقيله كدبابات
القتاليه والمدرعات التي قد يستغرق
تسليمها عده اشهر